the Joe Rogan experience there's a lot
of quotes out there from media and from
okay
from from pundits from Twitter users but
I only quote people who are well-known
either they're well-known journalists or
they're politicians but it usually goes
along the lines of exactly what you just
said you were worried about which is
Trump is more concerned about the the
stock market than people's lives all
right that's the kind of the typical one
you hear and know it's certainly been
been said quite a bit and my fear is
that it continues to be said okay I you
know and it prevents us from having a
reasonable debate because we we truly
need to have that reasonable debate the
other the other thing that frustrates me
about these kind of bad faith arguments
is that the people saying them made the
same claims themselves like February 1st
Washington Post here's a headline get a
grip America the flu is a much bigger
threat than the coronavirus okay
February 1st USA Today coronavirus is
scary but the flu is deadlier and more
widespread ok February 3rd Washington
Post why we should be wary of an
aggressive government response to
coronavirus and so these same papers are
now destroying the president all you
didn't act early enough you didn't do
anything it's and you have the blood you
have blood of people on your hands but
like that's amazing ideas
yeah the hypocrisy is insane and like I
have so many more go ahead New York
Times who says it's not safe to travel
to China so this is following president
Trump's extremely at the time a very
bold move to restrict travel from China
and you know and of course all of these
papers and prominent people are now
saying something different I go through
a timeline to where I look it because
again my my Democratic colleagues are
very quick to continue to accuse this
administration of just dropping the ball
doing all these bad things but I have to
remind everybody how this is this is a
good one on the same day that that Trump
implemented the restriction on
Travel this was it's the January 27th
okay and then they got they announced
the they announced the ban on travel as
well as the the task force January 31st
oh sorry the 34 the 31st the Trump
administration implemented the
restriction on travel January 31st and
also declared it a public health
emergency on that same day
Nancy Pelosi talked about a bill
promoted a bill called the no ban Act
which would limit the president's
ability to impose travel restrictions so
like you just you just can't say you
just can't say that this guy wasn't
acting in the public's best interest and
then then have facts like this when I do
remember this to and I pointed this out
at the time because you know a lot of
people were not talking about
coronavirus in February and on February
28th which is a few days before February
28th the the Trump admitted the 24 the
Trump administration asked for two and a
half billion dollars from Congress to
combat the spread so that was a money
that had already been spent by HHS by
CDC that needed to be reimbursed so the
Trump administration has already been
dealing with this and they're like hey
Congress we need more money we need more
supplemental funding he got slammed I
don't know if everybody remembers this
but he got destroyed he got told he
wasn't taking it seriously why isn't he
asking for more money the president's
response to that was okay fine give me
more money like I'm just write something
that that week you know if we voted on
in the House floor we didn't vote on
more money okay they had days to give
more money because this was earlier in
the week we actually voted on that we
close to 3 3 9 which is reversing the
youth tobacco epidemic act that was a
bill to ban flavored tobacco
according to House Democrats things like
hookah grisly wintergreen which is maybe
what I might like is now illegal now it
never got into law of course because I
never went through the Senate but I want
people to understand
like money I'm not blaming Democrats
either because there was a lot that we
all just didn't know and I just want I
just want to point these things out
because it's important to give each
other to grace to be like hey not
everybody knew what was happening
it wasn't until early March that it was
exploding as a virus in Iran and Italy
and South Korea these things happen and
it wasn't it wasn't clear that there
should be massive massive lockdowns of
society those are very bold moves and
it's so easy to have this 20/20
hindsight and and and act you know
holier-than-thou and pointing fingers
but it's it's highly disingenuous and I
and I built this whole time light out to
show it and I also point out that the
timeline can end you know the from here
on out we could just we could just give
each other some grace and and solve
these problems together because it will
be very easy to blame each other for the
deaths of Americans no matter what the
decision is it will be easy because the
counterfactual is impossible to prove
and the fact that it's so easy that
political opportunism is so easy is is
what worries me the most
and like we have to have those
conversations though about reopening
society and when to do it and we have to
have the conversations about this
political opportunism and and shaming it
and and calling it for what it is and
and really being honest with those
quotes from The Washington Post The New
York Times USA Today and letting people
know nope we didn't know what this was
we didn't see it coming and when it was
coming we were real confused as to what
the consequences were gonna be and we're
also not getting honest data out of
China right China China is just they are
not honest about the body count they're
not honest about any of it we don't
really know what happened over there the
version that we're getting is got holes
in it oh yeah let's talk about that I
did find the quotes that I told you I
had don't want to hear that sure they're
from people like Jen Rubin like CNN so
general Rubin Trump death tall equals
Trump dead lives that would have been
spared had he acted on warnings the rest
of victims the rest are victims of
Trump's stupidity and narcissism this is
from a prominent Washington Post
columnist again I'm not choosing random
twit
users you know from New York Times
President Trump was so focused on
fabricating threats involving Central
American caravans that he was oblivious
to the real threats so again I could
keep reading I have a bunch
[Applause]